I basically try to remind people that
this virus isn't just out in the
environment waiting to jump down your
respiratory tract it's captured it's
acquired from interacting with people
this is doctor Susan - I'm an associate
professor of Epidemiology I was not one
of those that rushed to a restaurant the
first weekend they opened up given the
opportunity in the spring
staying safe from covin 19 doesn't
require isolating in a bunker but it
does mean lean different risks based on
the situation it can think about
everyday activities in terms of the
three DS diversity distance and duration
diversity is the number of households
mixing so risk is higher if you're
meeting with people you don't live with
particularly if you don't know every
where they've been in the past two weeks
it's also higher if your area has had
lots of recent cases or if testing is
too limited to know how many active
carriers are around distance is an issue
whenever you're less than six feet from
other people especially if you're
indoors people who aren't wearing masks
lastly it comes down to duration are you
running past people in the park or are
you having an extended conversation or
encounter so the challenge that you have
is kind of translating that into normal
day-to-day behaviors pool party kinds of
situations there's food involved then
there's most more than likely in an
adult gathering alcohol involved I would
be concerned about mass wearing in that
context which actually should be part of
the mix when you're thinking about
distance and density those are two
things that can be really problematic to
maintain in that kind of an environment
and there may be social pressure not to
maybe the distance bars are you know
really designed to attract people in in
large numbers and and to get up close
and personal so that's one of the venues
that I am most concerned about when they
eventually are allowed to reopen houses
of worship very frequently the
population presence there is generally
older and potentially more vulnerable to
consequent
of coronavirus infection but there are
also lots of activities that can be
potentially really problematic we know
singing results in tremendous projection
of air and virus potentially group
sports when you're physically working
out you're going to be breathing a lot
harder and forced exhalation if you
happen to be infected is a great way to
expel a lot of virus in the gym context
what I've seen they have broken up those
banks of of treadmills they you know
remove some of the machines or space
them out to provide distance between
individuals on them I think the the real
challenges I think for in some respect
is for the trainer's the indoor dinner
party is also fairly high you may have
some reasonable distancing but probably
not enough and then when you're eating
you're obviously not wearing a mouse if
it's households commingling that's where
you know the real the real issue does
come in mass transit options basically
they're relatively small and closed
spaces with potentially lots of people
in them for an extended period of time
whether it's a surface bus or a subway
or an airplane you've got lots of
possibilities going on there that date
one-on-one making sure you know who it
is that you're having a date with before
you actually get into a physical
proximity with them is probably a really
good idea troll there social media to
see what they're posting and if they've
been to a couple of bars or parties
dental visits are close proximity
certainly with the dental hygienist for
an extended period of time and as a
patient your mouth is wide opening ready
to accept virus I'm assuming they would
scream physiologically any of their
patients I think the other kinds of
personal care and close interaction
services I mean we've seen the example
of what happens when a hairstylist goes
into work sick and that's really
problematic
Airbnb I think it really depends on the
proprietor and what kind of interval
they have between their guests because I
mean we know the virus will not survive
more than two or three days on any kind
of surface without renewed contamination
and so I would be very concerned about
an Airbnb that was flipping in the same
day from one client to the next in a
hotel I have a little bit less concern
although I would like to think that they
are leaving at least one day in between
guests in in individual rooms preferably
two days shopping in general is
relatively low but in a mall where there
may be opportunities for people to
gather is is what I would be concerned
about public pools the water itself is
not a risk but if that water is full
people you know shoulders shoulder
whatever it's it's a risk it's a risk
environment
I think campsites are relatively safe as
long as you're not again gathering
around the campfire in close proximity
with five other households walking in
the park or whatever where you're not
stopping and chatting for ten minutes
with an old friend you know I'm not sure
that you really even need to wear a mask
in that context because you're not
spending any length of time in proximity
to anyone unless of course it's the
crowded boardwalk in New Jersey or North
Carolina or wherever else all of this
varies from situation to situation and
person to person the 3ds may not be
enough if you're high risk or interact
with people who are as even moderate
risk can lead to major consequences
there are some people ready and willing
to accept the consequences of engaging
in certain kinds of activities but here
it's more than just about an individual
it's really about your collective sphere
of friends family and and those that you
interact with
[Music]